alexandre soljenitsyne vous a d'abord
vous remercier de m'avoir accordé le
privilège ainsi qu'à toute l'équipe
d'antenne 2 qui m'a accompagné ici de
privilège de passer une journée avec
vous dans votre famille et puis ce
privilège de l'entretien que nous allons
avoir dans votre bureau à la table même
où vous écrivez tout vos heures la
raison de cet entretien c'est la
publication à paris aux éditions imca
presse en langue russe de la version
définitive et complète 12 14
de même les éditions fayard viennent de
publier en france cette version
définitive et complète c'est-à-dire 400
pages de plus que la précédente version
de 12 14 et je signale ses 400 pages y
lisons été traduit du russe par
geneviève et je ne sais jouer mais quand
je remarque une chose sur ce gros livre
c'est que il ya marqué certes ou 2,14
milliards marqué la roue rouge
et puis premier ne qu'est ce que la roue
rouge
qu'est ce qu'un premier ne craint ce
n'est que les sauts et un rouge et le
récit de leur révolution russe et vassy
à la différence des renault le récit est
taxée non sur deux ou trois personnages
non sur deux ou trois lieux
géographiques
le récit embrasse des centaines de
personnages pour la plupart réel
historique
il embrasse également des dizaines de
lieux géographiques en russie c'est
comme le mouvement de la russie emportés
dans le tourbillon révolutionnaire
matière est immense il faut prendre en
considération qu'il s'étend sur
nombreuses années est obligé de
commencer à l'année 1914 le mener
jusqu'en 1922
impossible de décrire tant d'actions
tant de personnages sur une telle
étendue de temps pour cela j'ai choisi
pour mon récit la méthode des points
nodaux des neveux c'est à dire que je
choisis des segments de temps réduit à
deux ou trois semaines
là où se passent les événements les plus
pittoresques ou bien qui reste seul clic
les plus fondamentales de ces événements
et jeu décrit avec force détails
uniquement ses segments ce sont eux qui
forment les noeuds entre les noeuds je
ne décris rien et c'est en reliant les
points d'eau que je restitue la courbe
ci lieuse de ce mouvement
quatorze constitue le premier de ses
yeux le statu quo
oui mais il y aura combien de noeux et
combien sont écrits ce coin canapé ce
gaz est ici la donne et j'écris 3,9 en
août 14 octobre
on tourne ou plutôt novembre 16 mars 17
la révolution proprement je suis en
train d'écrire le quatrième
il en faudrait beaucoup mais
malheureusement ma vie sans doute
s'arrêtera avant que se terminer oui je
voudrais quand même mener ce travail
jusqu'au 7e 9 pour expliquer le pourquoi
de la révolution d'octobre
à partir de là tout deviendra clair